i
[Música]
con seis votos a favor y cinco en contra
de la corte suprema de justicia de
méxico declaró constitucional la
consulta popular propuesta por el
presidente de lópez obrador para decidir
si se enjuicia por corrupción a cinco ex
presidentes del país tendremos reporte
desde ciudad de mexico
al menos 3000 migrantes hondureños
cruzaron de forma irregular la frontera
de guatemala como parte de una nueva
caravana de migrantes que intenta llegar
a eeuu en lo que a 2020 han salido al
menos cuatro caravanas muchos de los
viajeros quedaron parados en guatemala y
tuvieron que devolver a su país por
cuenta de la pandemia
en el último día de audiencias la
justicia británica decidió que anunciará
el 4 enero del año 2021 su veredicto
sobre la extradición de julian assange
ya estados unidos que lo reclama por 18
delitos de espionaje e intrusión
informática castigados con hasta 175
años de cárcel en ese país
assange rechaza esta petición alegando
que eeuu tiene motivaciones políticas
muy buena noche gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 se revelan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en méxico donde la corte
suprema valoró la iniciativa del
presidente lópez obrador donde propone
que los ciudadanos elijan si la justicia
de investigar es y si es su caso llevar
a juicio a cinco ex presidentes de la
nación antes de la votación el
presidente de lópez obrador pidió en
conferencia de prensa a la suprema corte
que no negará al pueblo su derecho de
participación y exigió que se haga valer
a plenitud la democracia en el país
la pregunta originalmente incluía los
nombres de carlos salinas ernesto
zedillo vicente fox felipe calderón y
enrique peña nieto- ahora ya no los
tienen para proteger los derechos de los
ex mandatarios conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal en la capital mexicana a
mario du carbonell mario buena tarde
como todo entonces la nueva pregunta y
cuando se realizará esta consulta a la
ciudadanía
qué tal pues mira en la consulta quito
como ya lo mencionaban los nombres de
los expresidentes y quedó muy abierta
quedó incluso diríamos ambigua porque
precisa en la pregunta está usted de
acuerdo o no en que se lleven a cabo las
acciones pertinentes para emprender un
proceso de esclarecimiento de las
decisiones políticas tomadas en años
pasados por los actores políticos a fin
de que se haga justicia y se diga no se
protejan los derechos de las posibles
víctimas al mencionar actores políticos
decisiones políticas en años pasados
pues lo deja muy abierto ya no se
refiere en específico a expresidentes y
podría interpretarse como cualquier otro
cualquiera otra autoridad del poder
ejecutivo raúl cuando se va a llevar a
cabo bueno esto es un proceso porque de
llevarse a cabo en efecto esta consulta
tendría que ser el primer domingo del
año 2020
es decir no no está próxima esta
consulta en caso de que se realice ahora
mario si los mexicanos entonces se
siguen votar a favor de esta moción del
presidente obrador automáticamente se
procedería a un juicio contra estos
políticos y además le preguntó si
obrador podría ser también juzgado
bien en primera instancia la corte tiene
que devolver al senado de la republica
esta decisión para que el senado abra un
proceso de votación es decir no es en
automático que se realice esta consulta
primero tanto el senado como la cámara
de diputados deben votar para que se
lleve a cabo esta consulta si votan en
sentido contrario el asunto se archiva y
se da por concluido si dicen sí que se
lleve a cabo esta consulta entonces
tiene que dar aviso al instituto
nacional electoral para que realice las
gestiones conducentes a llevar a cabo
esta consulta entonces si el presidente
estaría
en este cajón digamos para poder ser
juzgado es abierto a interpretación raúl
porque al ya no hablar de expresidentes
sino de actores políticos que hayan
tomado decisiones en años pasados pues
solamente que se considerara su
actuación como jefe de gobierno de la
ciudad de mexico en años pasados porque
no está específico si se trata de ex
presidentes ex gobernadores en fin
entonces tiene todavía que llevar a cabo
este proceso en el senado después si el
40 por ciento de los participantes en
esta consulta dan su voto sería vince
delante y tendrían las autoridades que
aplicar este proceso judicial solamente
así así es mariah vamos a estar entonces
muy pendientes de lo que ocurre en
méxico en torno a esta consulta y
cambiamos de información porque cerca de
tres mil hondureños que intentan llegar
a estados unidos
cruzaron ilegalmente este jueves la
frontera entre honduras y guatemala las
autoridades del instituto guatemalteco
de migración acusar a las personas de
agredir a sus agentes y violar los
protocolos sanitarios de la pandemia de
kobe 19
amaya nos tiene todos los detalles en el
siguiente informe
una nueva caravana de emigrantes
hondureños recorren decenas de
kilómetros en medio de la noche miles de
hombres y mujeres siguen el camino de un
sueño difícil de alcanzar pero que les
da esperanzas de un futuro mejor porque
aquí la cosa que no podemos trabajar
juzgado y mayor de edad todos pero aquí
el estudio todo lo que es el trabajo no
podemos realmente queremos buscar una
vida mejor en nuestra buscar un futuro
mejor sea pues realmente lo que
necesitamos una vida mejor para nuestros
vídeos también para la familia también
en lo que va del año han salido al menos
cuatro caravanas de inmigrantes
hondureños la pandemia de kobe 19
agudizó la crisis en el país
centroamericano
este grupo partido del miércoles en la
noche de san pedro sula en el norte de
honduras hacia el punto de corinto
fronterizo entre honduras y guatemala
[Aplausos]
luego de caminar toda la noche una ola
de personas se congregó en la frontera
en nuestro país no hay médicos
suficientes para lo que uno necesita
entonces tenemos que inmigrar me
entiende para otro país las autoridades
guatemaltecas no lograron evitar el paso
de miles de hondureños en un mensaje
radial el director del instituto
guatemalteco de inmigración pidió
colaboración al país vecino pedimos a
las autoridades hondureñas que detengan
estos flujos en su territorio esto no se
puede repetir pero si miles de
hondureños sueña con llegar a eeuu el
presidente de trump que busca la
reelección en los comicios de noviembre
ha adoptado una línea dura hacia la
inmigración legal e ilegal en lo que
lleva en la casa blanca su
administración ha anunciado planes para
permitir que sólo 15 mil refugiados se
reubiquen en eeuu en el año fiscal 2000
21 que comenzó este jueves
vamos ahora hasta reino unido donde tras
el último día de audiencias y entre
pequeñas protestas en contra de la
extradición de julian assange la fuerza
británica vanessa bar y ser de
dictaminar al 4 enero 2021 se autoriza o
no la extradición del fundador de
wikileaks a eeuu país que lo reclama por
18 delitos de espionaje e intrusión
informática castigados con hasta 175
años de cárcel en ese país
la magistrada fijó la fecha de su
dictamen al término de un juicio de
cuatro semanas en el tribunal londinense
de old bailey en el que han declarado
numerosos testigos de la defensa del
fundador de wikileaks que rechaza su
entrega
assange quienes permanecerá en prisión
preventiva mientras sigue su proceso
considera que washington tiene
motivaciones políticas con su
extradición nuestro corresponsal en la
capital británica marcela gutiérrez nos
amplía la información
concluyeron las audiencias en este
juicio de extradición de julian assange
quien está luchando para no ser
extraditado a eeuu donde de ser
encontrado culpable podría enfrentar una
pena de hasta 175 años de prisión en una
cárcel de máxima seguridad el veredicto
final sobre si assange será o no
extraditado a eeuu lo sabremos en los
próximos meses probablemente el próximo
año mientras tanto la prometida de
julian assange este el amor y salió del
tribunal central
bailey para agradecer a los
simpatizantes de assange el haber estado
apoyándolo durante estas casi cuatro
semanas además advirtió que si assange
es enviado a eeuu sería una violación a
sus derechos humanos y también un
atentado contra la libertad de prensa
además se han unido a esta campaña para
evitar la extradición de assange y eeuu
figuras internacionales como el músico
roger waters y el
político brasileño luiz inácio lula da
silva el día jueves este jueves también
se liberaron decenas de globos blancos
con la leyenda de liberen a assange y
también para celebrar los 14 años de la
fundación de wikileaks
así las cosas entonces en reino unido en
torno a este juicio de julian assange y
así finalizamos el informativo aquí en
france 24 continué con nosotros muy
buena noche para todos hasta pronto
[Música]